Is it a good idea to start pitching before launching,
being able to provide leads?
Yeah, you can.
If you want the practice, you can.
I mean, I definitely think when you have a lead in hand,
it's the way that you say things
and the tone of your voice is different
because you actually have a lead.
You have the address.
You have the business, the customer's name.
You know the scope of work.
So I think it's more effective,
but have I gotten deals where we've done that?
And Lincoln, he helped me with some setting
a couple years ago, and we started doing that
and it worked.
So yeah, you can, but it's definitely more effective
if you have a lead in hand, just in my opinion.